today i'm going to take you more through
some through some stories of mine that
you know that are true you know i mean
um
i was a young man are the others not
true oh they're all true they're all
true everyone i tell you is true you
know what i mean um
i'm gonna take you through the age today
you know uh when i was about
13 years old i think maybe 13 or 14
years old i was going around stealing
cars you know
my homie came to me at school and he's
like hey you know your average 14 13
year old
wouldn't be doing the things that i'm
going to share with you guys but you
know i'm sharing it today because you
know i want a lot of 13 to 14 year olds
out there to know that
everything is not precious and big with
being a gang member you know everything
is not
the way they think you know the way they
portray it the way they paint a picture
of it you know there's a lot of
reality that [ __ ] happens to you and it
haunts you in the long run
when i was about 13 14 you know my homie
came to school and he was like hey man
he had a shoe box and i said
what's that you know so he opens the
shoe box and i see like maybe there's
like 300 keys
and they're all the same keys and i tell
them where he goes go ahead and grab a
handful
and i'm like what do i want to have food
for they're all the same key i'll just
take one
you say well they're the master keys to
all toyota celicas
from 87 all the way to 90. you know i'm
like
what do you mean the master key said you
could open the door you could start the
ignition the trunk
i said all right so he gives me a
handful i put in my pocket
well that night i get ready you know and
it takes me about an hour to get ready
because i want to crease my pants you
know i mean i want a crease man i
increase my underwear i tell you the
truth
so i get all creased up ready to go put
on my headband
and we go to a party me and my homegirls
we go to a party we're kicking it over
there and
i had my handbag real real low i used to
wear my [ __ ] lower
i could see everybody at waist level you
know i mean i wasn't worried about their
face i was more worried about their
hands you know i used to watch their
hands you know
see if they would reach in their pockets
if they would touch their waist you know
i was really on it you know and i got
schooled by my uncles they told me
always watch a man's hands and his waist
you know that'll tell you everything if
he reaches in his pockets when you get
close to him or
any sort of movement so you know i got
my bandana real
real low and my homegirl tells me hey
let's let's jam you know so i'm like all
right we're up there in whittier and i
tell her well you know what i don't feel
like walking
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna go
search around the area and i'm gonna see
if i can find us a car to take you know
and she says how are you going to take
it at that time i didn't know how to hot
wire yet yet
i told her i got the master keys to
toyota celicas so lo and behold
i'm walking i see this toyota celica man
they got some rims on it it's like a
light brown it's maybe like a tan color
i look inside it badass stereo the
interior is like leather
it's like it's a brand new toyota celica
it's probably about 89.
we're in that year so i'm think it's
about christmas time right about
christmas
so i get in i open the door i put it in
the door it opens i get in
i start it i'm like oh [ __ ] it's a stick
shift you know
i learned how to drive stick shift but i
learned how to drive and stolen cars i
must have learned about
[ __ ] about 15 clutches as i'm going
through you know
each car i'm burning clutches burning
clutches and i just leave the car there
you know a couple i would drive to the
riverbed
and park them you know i mean so the
streets won't get that hot you know
i tell you i'm not your average 13 14
year old my mind's thinking
a little bit quicker than others you
know i'm getting i'm listening a lot to
what people are saying you know at that
time because
i want to be that gangster that
everybody
fears everybody wants to be everybody
you know wants to hang around with i
just wanted to be that guy so
i get this car i'm inside it i start it
up
i put it in first gear everything's
going cool i grind it in the second
grinding the third i turn around the
corner
my homegirl's not there she's there with
her sister her other sister
and two of my homies from another hood
they're all right there and i'm going to
tell you
the celica they're not all that big so
they all want to get in i'm thinking
[ __ ] it it's a g
right anyways everybody get in so
everybody gets in
boom we get in well my homie gets in the
side of me and he tells me hey
i got something right here and i said
what you got so he shows me right
he got the strap right so i'm like oh
[ __ ] all right cool let's go
so we go we're searching we're looking
you know we're gonna go gang man we're
gonna shoot somebody bottom line
so as we're going we cruise down the
street my sister used to live and i knew
a lot of dudes used to kick it from the
enemy hood right there by my sister's
house
so we cruise up boom we go at this time
i switched places with
the homie he wanted to drive i wanted to
do the deed so
we go we hit a corner we see these foods
kicking
back on the porch you know i mean i do
my thing i put my beanie real low
i go and i bust on these foods now i
don't know if i hit anybody i heard some
screaming i've seen some people falling
but i don't know if i ever hurt anybody
or hit anybody but i shot at him
so as we shoot at him i jump in the
shotgun seat we're going and
we start hitting these dips we're going
down the street and he's hauling ass and
we're hitting these dips boom
and we're hitting him so hard that
sparks are coming out the back of the
car and i'm telling him slow down
slow down we're all right we're all
right he's like no i just seen a cop at
the
at the last block so i'm like so as soon
as we hit a corner
a cop turns the corner and we're face to
face with him he's got to stop saying
we're at a stop sign
i got the gun in my hand i have gloves
on i'm like oh [ __ ] i go look man drive
as fast as you can i go a matter of fact
let's switch places so right in front of
the cup we switch places
i just shot so i feel i want to drive i
don't want to leave him to drive because
i'm not going to trust in him
i'ma trust in my driving so i get in the
driver's seat
the cop sees everything goes down he
pulls up on the side of me tells me hey
uh
do you have license and registration i
look at him i tell him
you don't see how young i am i'm like 13
14 years old he's asking for
for license and registration i know you
can see how young i am i don't have no
facial hair or nothing i'm real young
so i tell him yeah yeah i got it so i
play him off i'm about to pull over
i pull over to the side i keep it i keep
i put in neutral
i'm looking through my mirror and i see
him you know he's doing his thing he
gets off the car as soon as he gets off
and he closes his door
[ __ ] it i put it in first boom let's go
i tell my homegirls man
i'm not stopping for nothing there's no
[ __ ] red lights no stop signs i'm not
stopping for nobody
so we come out this this residential
street we're going i must be doing about
45.
we come out to this to this main street
and i turn
and the whole car slides to the other
side of the street we barely miss this
old man coming in
in a truck we barely miss him i mean i
could see the dude's face like
we're looking right at each other our
cars slide right by each other right
so i'm going here we come now i'm going
down norwalk boulevard and it has
nothing but main streets that run
through it i got about a quarter mile
maybe to get to my hood and i'm like man
i ain't stopping so as i'm as i'm going
i'm telling my homies and home girls
i'm not stopping for no red lights lo
and behold here we come up to a red
light
i tell them look everybody just duck
that's all i could tell them
just duck i'm a duck we're gonna go
through the red light so as we hit the
first red light i remember
i tell him duck and i duck and we go
through the red light
i don't want to see if anybody's gonna
hit me you know i mean i don't i'm just
saying [ __ ] it let's go so we will run
one red light boom
we go we're hauling ass i can hear the
sirens
but i can't see behind me because my own
girl she has one of those big ass
hairdos they used to wear back then i
guess it was a cha-cha
i can't see through the [ __ ] rear
view mirror i'm not even tripping to
look through the side mirror
i'm trying to see the review to see how
far they are behind me
don't behold their way back there but i
can hear the sirens so i'm thinking
they're right behind me
i must be doing about 60 65 we're on the
main street
here comes another [ __ ] light it's
red again so i'm like [ __ ]
everybody get down i get down put my
head down the steering wheel we go
through it we just go through it i hear
cars almost hit me horns blasting
we go through and i'm thinking okay now
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do how am i
gonna get away from these [ __ ]
they're behind me i know there's at
least four cars behind me because as i'm
going down the streets
i see the cars of the cops parked on
each main street that i'm passing
they're waiting to get in back of me you
know me so i pass them boom i see them
boom
so we're going there must be about four
or five cars behind me but i'm hauling
ass now i'm doing about 60 65
and i'm hauling this and i'm thinking
there's little residential streets i'm
thinking i'm gonna turn down a
residential street
stop the car everybody get off and run
whoever gets caught gets caught
well as i'm going i turn down this
little residential street
and my [ __ ] car doesn't turn it
[ __ ] locks
up it just locks up i guess with all the
weight of everybody it's so small of a
car that it locks up
and it slides and where it slides into
is this feed store where my father used
to take me
when i was a young kid to go by pigeon
feed for his [ __ ] pigeons
i hit that [ __ ] store i go inside the
store
i end up killing [ __ ] chickens some
ducks i think i killed a dog
i don't know if i killed some animals
but as we hit
we hit and i come to after the wreck i
come to the [ __ ] car smoking
the windshield's busted because my
homegirl in the middle she went through
the windshield she's laying
over the dashboard on top of the [ __ ]
hood
my homie i look at my homie he's all
dazed me and my homie get my homegirl
and we pull her back and when we pull
her back
she has her [ __ ] forehead just sliced
open all the way on top and bud's just
leaking and i'm like
oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] my homegirl's face up all
she tells me is
run so as i'm thinking of running i
remember i dropped the pistol on the
on the floorboard of the car because i'm
looking for i don't have it finally i
grab it
boom i put it in my waist the door's
jammed from the wreck so i can't get out
but the window had
you know got [ __ ] up so it had kind of
fell so anyways i get my homies oh my
homie has like a screwdriver a hammer i
forgot and i break the window
now all this time that i'm breaking the
window and i pull my homegirl back the
cops ain't even there yet
i didn't know that the cops were maybe
like four or five blocks behind me
because
every red light i ran they weren't gonna
just run the red light the same way i
did it i did it they have sirens and
[ __ ] but
i was running them like [ __ ] it i didn't
care what happened so they were far
behind
i break the window i get out now there's
this alley i see and i remember this
alley when my father used to take me his
car remember this alley i can run down
so i run down the alley i run down the
alley i get to the next street
i make a left and i see this ups van
and this ups van it's still running you
know so i run and i get under it
i get under it i'm thinking the cops
ain't gonna see me all of a sudden i
hear
like it sounds like horses hooves you
know they're on the ground it's going
i'm like what the [ __ ] is that and this
big ass [ __ ] german shepherd i mean
big as [ __ ]
pure black [ __ ] dark ass eyes comes
running right up to the [ __ ] ups
truck and i'm thinking [ __ ] he's gonna
bite me
[ __ ] [ __ ] stops and he starts
circling around the ups van
and i'm like what the [ __ ] at that time
i didn't know that the ups van was
kicking off fumes
and the dog could only smell me up to
the ups man
but he's running in a circle now at this
time i don't know that this is a police
dog i'm thinking this is somebody's dog
that just chased me down the alley
but he's a big [ __ ] dog and i'm like
[ __ ] so i wait i wait and i say when he
gets to the [ __ ] far corner when he
circles around again he gets through
this far corner
i'm gonna break the other way so i wait
for him he gets to the far corner boom i
get out i start running again
i hear the [ __ ] right behind me i jump
a fence
i'm i jump a fence i heard a little
fence i look back and this [ __ ] just
leaves it
like nothing i'm saying oh [ __ ] this
who's on me now i know he don't belong
to someone else i'm thinking now in my
mind i'm saying [ __ ]
this is a [ __ ] canine my homies have
warned me before about the canines
and told me how to get away from them so
i'm like boom i look i'm running through
this backyard i look to the side and i
see a fence
and then it has a wall behind it and i'm
like [ __ ] if i can hit this fence get on
the wall pull myself up
this [ __ ] ain't gonna be able to jump
in sure enough i hit the fence
i grab the wall i pull myself up as soon
as i pull myself
up [ __ ] barely misses me you know he
barely misses me i feel the wind from
his mouth just
right at my leg and i'm like [ __ ] so i'm
on top of the wall i'm like oh this food
can't jump
up there i'm gone well as soon as i jump
down i hit the ground and as soon as i
hit the ground
i try to get up and i can't get up and
what the [ __ ]
my legs just like went out well i didn't
know when i wrecked
my knees had hit the steering wheel and
i had split both of my knees right here
well all the adrenaline for me running
as soon as i guess i hit the ground
my legs just gave out so now i'm pulling
myself through some ladies backyard
the reason i know it's a lady i'll tell
you right now why i know it's a lady but
i'm pulling myself through this backyard
i can see the [ __ ] chopper circling
i could hear all the cops there i hear
the dogs still so i pull myself
my homie comes out of hiding behind a
bush i guess
he ran one direction i ran the other
direction but we ended up in the same
[ __ ] backyard
and this is like seven houses down from
where we actually were actually wrecked
so
i see my homie run up to me he's like
what's up get up let's go i go i can't
run dog
just help me hide me somewhere so he
grabs me i remember he's dragging me
through the grass
and i'm trying to hurry because i can
hear the [ __ ] dog it's barking and
barking and then i hear
the cops and i'm saying okay it's a
[ __ ] canine i tell him stash me
somewhere
well he pulls me into this this house
and it got like a uh uh
in the backyard it got like a uh you
know like a patio
and in the patio there's a there's a
pool table and i tell them [ __ ] it pull
me to the pool table the pool table has
a green tarp over it i guess they
weren't using it
it had a green tarp over it and i'm like
[ __ ] put me under
so he puts me under there now i'm trying
to steady my breathing because i don't
want the dog or
the guy to hear me because they're
searching i can hear him searching
through the yards or getting closer
well my homie he gets up and he runs and
he gets into the garage there's a garage
right there there's a white door he gets
inside and he closes the door and locks
it
i can hear him so i'm kicking back i'm
waiting i'm waiting
and all of a sudden within [ __ ] i'd
say maybe 15 to 20 seconds after i'm
sitting there
the [ __ ] tarp just busted in my face
it's the [ __ ] dog and he [ __ ]
snatches my arm
well when he snatches my arm he snatches
my wrist
i grab like this and i [ __ ] grab him
by his mouth and i'm [ __ ] like really
[ __ ] bit he bit me like twice once in
the wrist once in the arm
so i grab him and i'm gonna [ __ ] rip
his mouth open like [ __ ] this dog i'm
gonna kill this dog you know he already
bit me twice
i've been bitten by dogs i hate being
bit so i grab this [ __ ] and i'm about
to [ __ ] by that time we slid out the
other side of the pool table from the
struggle
i'm about to rip this [ __ ] i'm gonna i
just want to rip his mouth open
all of a sudden boom i just see a white
light boom
and [ __ ] everything goes black when i
wake up
i [ __ ] wake up and this dog has a
hold of my arm
and he's [ __ ] just shaking it and i
see my whole arm just
you know as he's shaking my arms just
flinging back and forth and i'm like
what the [ __ ]
so i suck the dog i try to suck the dog
and he hits him in his nose he lets go
i guess the cop that runs me said some
[ __ ] to him he grabbed the dog pull them
off
the cops get on me they handcuffed me
okay they handcuffed me
now the cop comes and he puts his
[ __ ] foot on my face he says where's
your homie at
where's your home yet i know my homies
in the garage but i'm not going to give
up my homie you know i'm not going to
give him up i'm caught you know maybe
they won't catch him they'll just take
me
well he's asking me he's asking me and
he has this [ __ ] canine and he's
snapping in my face he's snapping
and i'm scared i'm only 14 years old the
cops got me you know i mean i don't know
where
i'm in the enemy hood i just shot at a
[ __ ] so i'm thinking damn
you know when they got my ass while he's
snapping and he's snapping
he asked me again he says i'm gonna ask
you one more time if you don't tell me
where it is i'm going to let the dog go
again
he goes where is he at i don't tell him
[ __ ] he lets the dog go
now the dog gets on my leg that's the
most excruciating pain i've ever felt
you know i mean like i stated earlier to
all you young kids that are young i'm 13
14 years old
at that age you're supposed to be at
disneyland you know what i mean
chuck e cheese you know birthday parties
you're not supposed to be out here
shooting at people
stealing cars running from the cops you
know but
i chose to do that those were my own
choices well
he lets him go he's chewing on my
[ __ ] leg i'm screaming
i'm screaming i'm asking him to get the
dog off me never once did i give up my
homie
he takes the dog off me at that time
another canine comes in
and i'm like oh [ __ ] he's gonna stick
another one on me now there's two
canines
well lo and behold that canine runs up
to that [ __ ] white door and he's
jumping on the door and he's barking
and they're giving commands to my homie
inside hey come out
i'm put the dog on you come out unlock
it i hear my homie inside
all right i'm coming out i'm coming out
he unlocks the door
[ __ ] as soon as that door opens that
[ __ ] canine jumps on him
hits him in the chest pushes him down i
hear my homies screaming
i mean it was ironic because i if my
homie heard me screaming
i heard him screaming after they chew
his ass up
both his legs they didn't get his arms
because he put his arms behind his back
to handcuff them
and i guess from what i found out
whenever they release a canine on
someone
they have to let them bite you you have
to remember that they can't just
let a k-9 go bite you or then the next
time tell them not to bite you
and then to bite you they can't tell the
dog to do back and forth because the
dog's gonna get confused
so he has to bite you every time so they
get us both
they take us back to where the car is at
the [ __ ] cars total that [ __ ] is
smashed
it just got smashed like a little
[ __ ] box my home girls are handcuffed
and everything they know that the
amulets are attending to her
and i tell them i look at my homegirl
she's like i'm okay i'm okay i'm like
all right
so they take us from there they put us
in the paramedics they take us to a to
some hospital in pico rivera it's called
the dog and cast hospital
the dog and cat hospital they take us
there you know they're cleaning our
wounds and [ __ ]
and then they're asking how old are you
how old are we i tell them i think i'm
14
homies 14 yeah we're about the same age
14 and 15 they tell us we're taking you
to
the general hospital to the jail ward
now the jail award is for adults but i
guess if you're 14 years old and up they
take you to the jail ward
so they take me to the 13th floor of the
jail ward i get to the jail ward you
know the nurses are being nice and
everything
they clean my wounds all of a sudden i
hear my grandfather's voice
he's in the hallway he's talking [ __ ] to
the arresting officer because he's
telling him
do you know my grandson is 14 years old
you know you stick the canines on him
you know
i guess my grandfather spoke to the lady
that that house belonged to
because as that dog was biting me i
didn't know that the lady had came out
the house and seen the dog biting me and
told the cops
to take the dog off me she seen that i
was just a kid so she's telling the cops
take take the dog off them
i didn't hear that i only hear my own
screaming you know i'm [ __ ] yelling
the dogs buying the [ __ ] out of me
so my grandfather's arguing with this
cop they come in
they come back in they tell me hey we're
taking you to juvenile hall
so i'm like all right whatever we go to
juvenile hall i get to juvenile hall
we go to court in a couple days they let
me out i go home my [ __ ] arms is big
you know my legs is big i can barely
walk can't even move
my [ __ ] right side so you know i got
[ __ ] up
that time so long behold i heal
everything's cool you don't mean i go to
i don't even go to jail for that one
so lo and behold we're kicking it i grab
my little cousin it's about maybe about
two three months later i grab my little
cousin i tell him hey
let's go over here to this spot you know
what i mean i got this girl pregnant you
know she's gonna have a baby shower
let's go over here
he says yeah but it's close to the enemy
hood i said i'm i don't trip those foods
ain't gonna know
so we go over there we get inside we're
kicking it i get to the kitchen and i'm
rolling a joint you know i mean i'm
rolling a joint
and i i remember i'm about to lick the
joint and i hear the front door open and
i look to the side
and four [ __ ] walk in and the
first dude i recognize him i'm like oh
[ __ ] this fool has my ass this fool
right here has already erased
[ __ ]
so and what i mean by a race you should
know what i mean he erased him got rid
of him and i'm like oh [ __ ]
i ain't got a gun i ain't got a knife i
ain't got nothing he's coming in the
door
i'm thinking how in the [ __ ] does this
[ __ ] know we're here well
i was [ __ ] with his homegirls about
three months previous
and they got upset and his hunger
decides to let them know where we're at
so we go you know me we're in there i
roll a joint
i'm licking it here he comes in has a
few words with my cousin
you know what i mean my cousin tells him
step outside the dude walks out my
aunt's in there because it's a baby
shower
they're telling us to calm down whatever
as my cousin's coming out the end
i [ __ ] pull a knife out give it to
him i grab me something we go outside
we end up whacking these [ __ ]
in front of everybody
what i mean by whacking is we stab these
dudes i mean one of the dudes was
stabbed so much that they took him to
the hospital
you know what i mean and no more we
didn't get caught
but i knew that these dudes had the
reputation of coming back
so about a week later i'm kicking it and
i'm barbecuing some steaks on the grill
or inside the apartment complex kicking
in and barbecuing on the grill
and i look up and i see four individuals
walk
up one got a shotgun the other one got a
handgun the other one got a handgun
i figure i'm through i have a nine
millimeter in my back i had just bought
a nine millimeter i have it in my back
so i pull it out we all aim boom at the
same time we all aim
and the older dude says what's up man
you know i guess the dude
that we had stabbed made up a story he
made up a story that
i asked him to come and kick it with us
and that i set him up
and then we jumped him and we stabbed
him and that's how it happened it didn't
happen like that
the dude stats slapped my aunt so i
stabbed the [ __ ] out of him
for slapping my aunt you know i can't go
home and face my family them being all
gang members and tell them hey
i was at a party your sister my aunt got
slapped and i didn't do [ __ ]
you know so this older dude asked me hey
man you set up my homie i said
i said nobody up your homie came and
slapped my aunt
so he asked me well who's your aunt as
soon as i told him who my aunt was
he started slapping the [ __ ] out of one
of his homies that had the gun he
started pistol whipping with the gun
boom he's pissed a whipping with the gun
i'm like hey wait up man you know dude
wasn't even there you know i mean
a lot of times that i got into incidents
i noticed that
when the truth comes out the older dudes
that are taking care of business
always start either slapping their
homies beating their homies pistol
whipping them and i'm wondering why
they're doing that they came with them
to handle business
but yet when the truth comes out they
start beating on them several occasions
i have had dudes
beating on their homies behind me just
giving the truth i feel that the truth
will outlast anything a lie changes you
know what i mean and
dude was running his mouth but as soon
as i told the older dude what happened
they put the guns down he starts pistol
whipping his homie i ask him to leave
him alone
then i get a conversation with the older
dude you know me and i tell him look man
this is what happened i ran him down
what happened i let him know who my
family was
he said cool nothing will come from this
all right cool i'm i ain't tripping
so about i say three days later me and
my homie are kicking it and i'm selling
glass at that time but it's it's peanut
butter crank i'm selling peanut butter
crank right
and somebody tells me go inside and
check on my my girlfriend you know so
i get up i go check out my girlfriend as
soon as i'm walking to the front door
i hear some voices so i look out the
window
and i see the same exact dude that i
stabbed
he has my homie on the ground with the
shotgun through his face
and he's asking him where i'm at now
he's asking him where i'm at
i left my gun in another apartment and
i'm like [ __ ] i don't have my gun on me
this who has my homie i'm like he's
gonna kill my homie
he doesn't kill him he he's asking only
for me you know what i mean and i knew
they were coming back again
so what i did was i made a phone call i
called it homies i said check it out
this fool came back again
you know me and he had my homie with a
shotgun to his face my homie's upset
you know i'm either going to take it to
my older homies and we're going to go
over there to your hood and [ __ ] your
homie off or you guys are going to [ __ ]
him off because
from my understanding it was supposed to
be over but you always got to remember
when you're in the gang scene and you
tell somebody that it's the end
it's never the end because somebody's
always related to somebody else
you know me someone has a little brother
you know the dude that i stabbed
he ended up picking up a life sentence
about five years later
i'm kicking at this apartment and we're
getting high and
three or four or five dudes walk in and
i recognize one of the dudes he looks
real familiar
and asking me what's your name he tells
me his name and then he tells me my
brother's so-and-so and i'm like
[ __ ] how am i gonna tell this kid that
i'm the one that did that to his
brother's face you know
and then he comes and he tells me um you
know who my brother is man
and i'm like man i don't want to tell
this young kid well he's younger than me
he's not really that young he's
about four or five years younger than me
but i don't want to tell him what i did
to his brother because
he's gonna get upset and he's i'm gonna
have to hurt the little [ __ ] but
i tell him anyways man look this is what
happened with your brother he was there
with your home and your homie [ __ ] up
your brother got
served because of your homie but it's
all over and done with
so i ended up kicking with this little
youngster you know what i mean and he
was a solid dude you know i mean he was
good and everything
and he tells me hey you know um he says
the fool's from
he says another gang he goes i've been
trying to put him work on him but i
can't find him
well they're the enemies of us too so i
tell them well check it out i'll go with
you
what we'll do is we'll take two cars the
front car will leave with girls inside
now this is how i used to do it
the front car will have all women inside
the bad car will have all guys inside
with the firearms loaded up with the
guns what we would do is we would let
the home girls cruise up
call these dudes now these dudes see all
women in a car they're thinking [ __ ] it
they roll up on them you know i mean hey
girl what's up
my homegirls whistle call these dudes
were
a little bit ways back with no lights on
as soon as the dudes walk up to the car
my home girls know as soon as they see
us come up they leave
so we drive up they leave this little
youngster
don't reach out the window he jumps out
the window
runs chases the dudes in the backyard i
hear a gang of firing going on
i mean he must unload the whole clip on
these dudes
he runs back in he gets in and i see him
he's white as a ghost you know and i'm
like what the [ __ ] i take off right we
leave
we're in a g right we leave as we're
going down the street i'm looking at him
right
and he puts his head between his legs
and he he just throws up inside the car
and i'm like
[ __ ] i ain't never seen anybody throw up
i never threw up you know i mean i think
i threw up one time i seen something and
i threw it one time but
i don't know what he did but he threw up
in the car and i'm like [ __ ]
let's get another car [ __ ] this car it's
starting to smell you know he he threw
up a lot in there
and he's telling me oh just take me home
just take me home i'm like i'm not going
to your hood to take you home
[ __ ] that if i go to his hood to take
him home he lives like right in the
heart of his neighborhood
i ain't going in there so i tell him
i'll leave you at the corner i leave him
at the corner
he goes home about i say about five days
later
he calls me again he tells me man these
fools came
came back shot two of my homies what's
up could you take me on another mission
i'm like look man i told him look like
this time i'm about 16 years old i tell
him look man
our hoods don't get along but we're not
really enemies
but since that happened with your
brother and
you know what happened i'm gonna take
you again you know so
i go and i pick this youngster up he
comes running out of his house
he looks happy you know he don't look
the same way he looked at one day when i
dropped him off
he looks like a whole new person he
comes in
he got this rifle it's it's i think it's
a 22 rifle and it has a banana clip
and this [ __ ] banana clip is
see-through and i'm looking at it i'm
like damn this [ __ ]
i mean this banana clip must be about
this long and
it it's shaped like a banana and it's
loaded all the way down and i'm like
what are you gonna do he's like look i
went over here and i wrote
on the wall he goes these fools are
gonna come
and cross me out and i want to be across
the street and i'm gonna light him up
and i was like damn this fool's young
he's like 13 years old i'm thinking
how would a 13 year old think of
something like that
i've never thought of that and i've
thought of everything i thought of
jogging through the park
i thought of jogging up on guys with a
wig on i've tried everything
but this dude's talking about he wrote
his name and [ __ ] on the wall
he's gonna wait for them to cross it out
so we sat there we must have sat there
for like an hour man i'm already getting
tired of sitting there
we smoked like three four drones we
smoked the lovely
i'm high as [ __ ] we're drinking we're in
the g right i'm like but we're sitting
in a g right here on a main street he's
like man they're gonna come they're
gonna come
i say about half an hour after he tells
me they're gonna come
here comes two guys and they're coming
they cross the street we're watching
them
you know we could see their gangsters
because at that time you know for you
young kids that don't know
you know back then you could spot a
gangster anywhere you could see a crowd
of 50 people
and there could be two or three people
sticking out because of the way they
dress
the way they look the way they walk the
way they talk the way they look at you
you know they're gang related nowadays
you can't even tell
but back then we see these guys walking
across the street and i'm like okay we
got him we got him
i said what do you want me to do you
want me he's like no don't drive up on
him i'm gonna walk up on him i'm like
this kid's crazy you know what i mean he
wants to get off the car and handle his
business and then come back to the car
you know
for any of you know that have went on
missions from a [ __ ] to handle
business and come back to the car
it's not him handling business it's you
getting away
that's the number one thing getting away
so
he handles his business and i always
remember
how this situation looked because i'm
watching it like i'm watching a tv
he walks up to the two dudes they're
spraying on the wall and he just starts
letting off on them
and i always remember these dudes were
like i always told people that
if you can ever make a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] pop lock you know because
every time he hit him
the dudes were like just shaking you
know like they were they were pop
blocking like
he was just hitting both of them he let
the whole clip off on both these fools
either one of them hit the floor they
were able to run i mean
they were leaking i know they were
leaking because he shot him a lot of
times
he comes back the gun's smoking the
clips empty he [ __ ] empty the whole
thing and i think it was a 32 or a 38
round clip
he empties the whole [ __ ] thing on
him and i'm like i look at him he gets
in the car
he's [ __ ] stone white again i'm like
look who if you're gonna throw up
tell me you're gonna throw up oh stop
the car [ __ ] we get about three blocks
she's like
dr car stop the car i'm like what what
stop the car [ __ ] i stop the car
he gets out he's throwing up i tell him
get the [ __ ] in the car we're only three
blocks away
from where he did the actual shooting
i'm like get in the car he gets in the
car we go
he tells me hey let's go kick it at my
house at this time he had moved
a little bit out of his hood so we go
kick it at his house
i love to kick it at his house his
sisters he got like four of them they're
beautiful
so i started messing with them you know
what i mean i'm being with the sisters
the phone rings one day
i answer it i never should have answered
it it was his brother calling from
prison
i answered hello his brother his
brother's 18 got a life sentence i think
he got like something like a hundred of
life 98 life or something
for killing somebody in in a liquor
store so i answered the phone alone
you know it's collect call from this
state penitentiary move i said i accept
it
hello he's like who's this and me
instead of saying i'm someone else i
tell him who it is he [ __ ] blows it
on the other end i'm like
i put the phone down i call one of the
scissors i'm like your brother's on the
phone
they get on the phone with the brother
the little brother gets on the phone
he starts talking to his older brother
now his older brother wants to talk to
me so i get back on the phone
and i'm young this dude's a little bit
older he tells me man what the [ __ ] are
you doing taking my brother around
handling his business i said check it
out your brother calls me
i don't go call him he said your brother
calls me
you left him out here he's not my
responsibility he's yours
you know because i'm a strong believer
in if you have a little brother and a
little sister
it's your responsibility to guide them
in the right way me i guided my little
brother in the wrong way
you know i mean i took my little brother
on missions me and him did so much [ __ ]
that
sometimes i feel guilty about the things
that i took my little brother to do
but in my mind i know that my little
brother if he ever talks on here
i think he's just a little bit more
treacherous than i am a little bit more
dangerous
and he's just a little bit more crazy
because he's the type of [ __ ]
that
he'll let your air out and he won't give
a [ __ ] he'll want to eat right after
go [ __ ] drink something he don't
throw up he don't get sick he doesn't
get scared he doesn't duck you know me
we've been shot at several times
we stand in the front yard fool came by
with a [ __ ] mozberg shotgun hanging
out the window
and i remember this dude [ __ ] let off
that [ __ ] shotgun
and i hit the ground and when i look up
my little brother's just standing there
you know and
he's he don't duck and i ask why don't
you duck he says what happens if i duck
and dude shoots me when i'm on the floor
[ __ ] it i'ma stay still let him shoot
you know and i wish i could bring him to
speak to you guys
as well because i'm trying to find him i
can't find him i'm trying but
he's a little more treacherous than i am
you know but he was my little brother
and i feel guilty that
if you have a little brother you
shouldn't take him through the stages
that i took
him through you know what meaning
because i used to think of things and
the time my little brother let's go he
wouldn't hesitate
we'd go do something and then we
wouldn't want to come outside at all
i shared that before we wouldn't come
outside at all just for what we did out
there on the streets
you know so this little youngster that i
got with me
now that his brother said it's okay and
he can roll with me i keep this little
youngster with me because
number one he's not afraid to handle
business number two
he doesn't run his mouth he's not the
type of [ __ ] that will go around
and tell a story because if you do
something to get away with it
when you tell it again it's like doing
it all over again i share these because
these happen many many years ago i only
did my time for most of them
and i'm sharing with you guys what i've
experienced to let you know
everything is not good when after i ran
with this little youngster
i ended up going to juvenile camp for a
whole year you're only supposed to be
do three months but because i was in
juvenile camp and i was from a gang
and because my gang got along with a lot
of gangs around us
but what happened was i went and did a
little juvenile time
i got out got to the park there's
another gang another gang and another
gang with my gang there
and i'm wondering what the [ __ ] are
these other gangs doing here well what
they're doing is
they want to all kick it together and
declare war on everybody else
so now when i go back to jupiter when
i'm in july the first time i'm running
into games that i get along with
when i circle around and come back the
next time this is the bad part
i come back the next time all these
dudes that i was kicking with they're
all my enemies now now i gotta fight
with all of them
and they want my enemies to begin with
they were the enemies of this dude's
hood but since we get along
we probably got along with this hood and
they didn't they did and they didn't
so we'd party with them this field would
come would get into it with them
but we're with them and it wouldn't work
like that so we said [ __ ] it
since that's happening and it keeps on
happening you know you guys are kicking
it with someone and we're getting into
[ __ ]
it happened we're kicking here one day
right we're kicking it with these dudes
and three carlos pull up and we're like
when the [ __ ] is that dog
and these dudes tell us who it is and
we're like what the [ __ ] how do you guys
bring these [ __ ]
we get into with them shots are [ __ ]
exchanged
somebody dies on that side
it happened we had the we had the
meeting and we said [ __ ] it let's get
along we declare war on everybody
i went back to juneau i had the roughest
time in juvenile hall that was my
roughest time ever
waiting to go to placement i [ __ ]
must have fought like 15 times went to
the hole like 10 times
because of the fact that all these dudes
i used to kick it with now they know
they're my arch enemy
not because we did anything to their
hood but because we get along with a
hood
that don't get along with them so that
just makes for my enemy instantly so i
got all these [ __ ] enemies
i go to camp and there must be like 15
[ __ ] i don't get along with
and when you get to camp you have to
line them up for you kids that don't
know when you go to juvenile camp you
have to line up your enemies
one at a time and you're going to fight
with every one of them because if you
don't fight with one
they're going to label you as that a
loser a level whatever you want to call
it and
you're going to get all your [ __ ] took
all your stories going to get taken
you're going to [ __ ] pay somebody to
take care of you
in other words you're going to be like a
punk you're going to be like somebody's
woman you know everything you get from
your family
he's going to get what he wants out of
it and then give you what he wants to
give you
you know what means so you have to
remember doing time ain't
all what it seems to be don't get me
wrong before when i went to prison the
first time
as soon as you get to jail you get a
care package
boom soups coffee tobacco whatever you
want
then your homies send you something you
got [ __ ] like you just went to store
you go to jail now they won't even give
you a [ __ ] shot of coffee
you know you sit in a room maybe like 23
hours out of the day
they let you go eat use the bathroom
when you have to but you're in a room
the door's locked and you sit there for
hour after hour no books
no games to play you can't use the phone
nothing like that you just sit there
and wait until you go to court and then
you gotta wait again until they send you
either the placement
camp and as you're going through that
whole process you're fighting left and
right left and right and i mean you
can't show no kind of weakness because
if you do
like i said they're going to take
advantage of you they're going to take
your money that comes your story that
comes whatever thing you have that you
think is yours
it's not yours anymore you have to give
it up before you want to go to juvenile
hall you want to go to jail you have to
remember
those things come at a very very large
price your record and your jacket just
gets bigger and bigger and every time
you go to court and they see you
that's the first thing the judge sees
your record if you have a bad one
he's going to send you to the most
nastiest places there are and they got
nasty ass places where the staff there
treats you like [ __ ]
they don't say uh uh how you doing mijo
or how you doing baby kid no
hey [ __ ] you don't mean or a
stupid you know they talk to you very
very bad they're not your parents
you know they just they they make you
feel
like you're so little you're so small
like you don't want to come back anymore
but you know once you get out there
you're going to do the same thing over
and over i knew at 15 years old
when i put my teardrop on my face that i
was destined for prison
when i came home and everybody cried
because i had a tear drop on my face
my grandmother was only one not crying
because she knew
that i was gonna go to prison eventually
and i already knew i just didn't know
when
i didn't know i was going to go at 18 i
thought maybe 21 25
but i went at 18. you know and at 18
years old
you're supposed to be graduating high
school going to your prom
i didn't go to no prom i didn't graduate
high school i graduated high school in
prison you know and that's not the place
to graduate yeah they gave me a gallon
and a hat
and took one picture but i didn't get to
go and party with my homies my homegirls
you know my friends from school
[ __ ] no i made it to the 10th grade and
that was it by the 10th grade i had a
girl pregnant
you know what i mean i had a
responsibility now now i got to be a man
and i'm still just a kid you know so
when you got those years as being a kid
they used to tell me hey be with all the
women you can either you're young
do everything now that you're young when
you get older you're going to wish you
were young again
now i see that now that i'm older yeah i
wish i was young again
because i would have did certain things
different not saying that
i sit here and i hate my lifestyle no at
times i love my lifestyle
there are times there was times before
when i loved to pump fear into people
you know just to look at them in a
certain way and you see them shake
or you see their eyes move a certain way
you know you got them i used to be that
individual
nowadays i'm not that individual anymore
i don't promote violence
i'm a violent [ __ ] when it comes
down to it you know but i got that guy
that
bad bad person and locked him up so down
deep inside that i don't want to let him
out because if he comes out
i know i'm going back to jail you know i
took so many risks out there being a
young man
14 15 16 stabbing people jumping people
people that i didn't even know you know
maybe they got something with my homies
down the road
and i was the one that always i didn't
want to raise my hand and say i'll do it
i was just the one to say
give me the [ __ ] i'll go handle it and i
always used to do that
over and over and it cost me so much it
cost me my wife
my kids most of my life you know i've
been out of prison maybe like
10 years now and it only seems like a
year it went by so fast
you know and in jail you know you must
get a routine down
and you must follow all rules you know
and rules are there
they're not meant to be broken you can
bend them stretch them
put them in any way you want but you
can't break them you know what i mean
and
i tell you this because people glamorize
being a gangster being in prison if you
really think about it you shower with
men
you're around men all day you're not
around no women if you're lucky you'll
get family visits
but if you kill somebody or you almost
kill somebody you're not never gonna see
your wife
you're never gonna spend three days with
her in a little house
for for three days with your kids and
your wife you're not gonna get that they
don't give that to
to those type of people the people that
are very violent you know i used to be
i used to like to be one of the most
violent [ __ ] i could be you
know anything that came about and i
thought i was right man for the job
i would just do it i wouldn't ask i'll
just do it i wouldn't raise my hand
because
i didn't want to be picked on and say
okay it's your turn and then me to say
nah i never
yes i did i asked to do something i
raised my hand so much that now
this next [ __ ] that has a little
bit more juice he raised my hand for me
you know and in juvenile hall it's not
like that in juvenile hall
you get to keep your pride and
everything tucked inside because
dudes will talk about your mother talk
about your sisters talk about your
brother talk about your girlfriend
you know they'll try to break you in any
way they can because there's children in
there
but a lot of those guys think at a
higher level you know you're when you're
in the gang life you know you see things
that the average
youngster wouldn't see you know what i
mean i've seen people get shot i've seen
people get knocked the [ __ ] out
get their pockets checked pulled out
like a rabbit and just left there
you know and me being young i'm thinking
man i should go help that guy but then
when i try to go hop on my home he's
gonna leave that [ __ ] there and
kick him in the face again
you know and make me kick him in the
face again you know on my first mission
i got took
by my family member you know and i
didn't want to go i was [ __ ] scared i
was only like 13 14 years old 15. i was
15.
and they were taking me to go handle
business and i'm not going to sit and
say i wasn't scared i was scared as [ __ ]
but after i handled my business then it
became like a routine to me
i wanted to find the individuals that
were putting in work and every hood i
wanted to find that
individual and i wanted to [ __ ] him off
and
to tell you the truth a lot of times i
did find the individual and i did get
with the program and i see him nowadays
and those things are of the past but
the animosity is still there you know
what i mean and when you want to be
that [ __ ] remember your
reputation will exceed you
right now i'm dealing with something
that ain't even none of my business i
wasn't even there
but they put me as the culprit and it's
[ __ ] up because
who am i to go tell what really took
place that's none of my business
remember i wasn't there but if you want
to be that gangster and you think you're
that gangster
go ahead more power to you but you want
to be the best gangster you can be
don't half step nothing because
everything follows you
everything follows you i was at a party
one time i don't even know this [ __ ]
dude
and he came up and sucked me in my mouth
busting my mouth
and i don't even know this guy i've
never seen him i don't know who he was
afterwards i found out that i had
stabbed his brother like six months
previous
his brother i don't know this guy he
bust me in my outer front
everybody sat me on my ass i'm getting
up wiping my mouth i don't even know
this guy i'm trying to ask him who in
the [ __ ] are you he's just cussing at
the top of his [ __ ]
at the top of his breath just cussing at
me i'm like i don't even know this dude
but that's a consequence that you suffer
you want me from a gang
you have to remember every [ __ ] thing
your homies get into
you're going to be held accountable
especially if you're one of the homies
that is always there
because you've got homies that are
always there like i wanted to be always
there
you know me and always a woman wants to
be next to you
there's no room for women in a gang life
that's how i feel before i used to have
my homegirls and feel cool about them
but now i feel that there's no room for
women because when you go to jail
there's no women there there's only men
if you're a woman in jail you know what
you are you know so there's no room
for any women if i get on the phone and
i'm calling you get a hold of somebody
and a woman answers i don't want to
speak to a woman i want to speak to a
man
because he could put himself in here
she'll never come in here
she can get dealt with out there but in
here in jail when you're in jail
you have nowhere to run to know where to
hide you have to deal with everything
face value you're not going to be able
to go the next door and think you're all
good
shit's going to follow you everywhere
you go you know because
you know it used to be where you used to
write on the wall and you put your name
and then your neighborhood now it's
flipped backwards
you put your neighborhood then your name
wait a minute it's supposed to be you
representing your hood not your hood
representing you but everything's
[ __ ] backwards now
a lot of stuff is similar in the same
but a lot of things nowadays
are changed you know there's no
camaraderie anymore
i'll be the first to let it be known
that the camaraderie is not there
anymore before
[ __ ] would go out of his way to
bring your old lady to visit
now if you ain't got no gas and you
ain't got no money your lady ain't
coming up this guy's not gonna just
volunteer to have his old lady pick your
old lady up from 10 miles
away and then bring her over to visit
you it's not going to happen
so you youngsters that are running
around out there right now believe me
take it from someone who knows
when you go to jail you got to remember
are you going to be
a south sider or a rag rider that's what
they say if you're a south sider
you're going to put in work but remember
80 of the work you put in
is how you represent yourself how you
stay clean
how you follow rules how you talk to
people respect people the other ten
percent
is just putting in work people think
it's the other way around no
eighty percent of it is representing the
other ten percent is putting in work
it's not ten percent of representing
yourself and eighty percent of putting
work
it doesn't work like that because
remember you're in a jail you're in a
cell
so you can only get to people at a
certain time you know i shared a lot of
things up here and i share with you guys
because
i don't want to glorify anything i did
but this has been my lifestyle and i've
shown
i've said it before that some of us have
a choice
some of us don't so i was braided from a
young age
to be somebody that maybe in reality i
didn't want to be
but i became that person from a young
young age where
before i used to hurt a [ __ ] i
could be talking to you we could be
talking i see somebody
i go handle him smash his ass he's
bleeding and everything
come right back to you and just be able
to talk to you again like nothing ever
happened
you know what i mean and people used to
ask me how in the [ __ ] do you do that
how do you turn it on like a light
switch and then just turn it off
i don't know it was just inside me where
i could just handle something come right
back and be the same person
you know that's a bad bad person because
i had no conscience
of what i did and i heard a guy tell me
before i have no conscience
me i had a conscience but i used to just
tuck it way back where i say well
i just did that because it was the right
thing to do and you know they'll get
even
and i'll get even again we'll just go
back and forth like a tennis game you
know and
you know it's it's it's you're so caught
up in the moment that
when i went to prison the first time i'm
gonna be honest they offered me three
years
to go to prison i end up getting 15. but
they offered me three
the reason i didn't take the three
because i thought i could beat this
i didn't beat it i lost they offered me
three years i would have been out in a
year and a half
instead i went they gave me 15 and i did
seven of that
but i was offered three why because my
pride me being that [ __ ] that i
thought i was oh [ __ ] it i'm taking it
all the way the box and i lost
went to prison for seven years and the
first seven oh man it was
it was dynamite i had fun i wrote i rode
around in the yard with the homies we
smoked bug
drank had fun [ __ ] pudding work went
to the hole got out
but now it's not the same you're not
gonna go to the yard and smoke weed and
put in work
nah because all the homies you know are
either dead
doing life in the shoe or on the other
side
or they say the grass is greener i don't
know i haven't i haven't been outside
i never choose to go on that side and i
don't knock nobody for going to that
site people have their own reasons
but me myself i'm a strong believer in
when you were on the streets
and you were putting in work and they
stabbed you or they shot you
you went home the hospital home and you
healed up then you went back out there
and began banged again
what's the difference of going to jail
and in jail you get poked
why would you archwage your door shut
why lock it up
go yourself heal up let yourself fill up
come back and handle your business if
you were doing it like a gangster
why not do it in prison the same way
you're just in a different environment
but if you're a real [ __ ] and
you can call yourself a solid south
sider then you should be able to adapt
to anything that you find yourself in if
you find you could put me on a street
corner on any [ __ ] street corner give
me a sack
and i'll be able to deal drugs you can
set me on the street corner get me five
women
i'll pimp them all okay you can do that
you can put me anywhere and i'll be able
to become
a product of my environment because i'll
watch
i'll study and i'll just become a part
of that where yeah i might stick out
like a sore thumb
but in reality i became a part of that
environment i don't feel that
i was ever institutionalized no i feel
that i just came accustomed
to doing the same [ __ ] thing that
over and over again
and they'll tell me that i'm crazy that
i'm crazy to come out here
and i got busted for dealing drugs i go
to jail come back out
i'ma deal drugs again and expect a
different outcome
how is that i'm gonna get the same
outcome i'm gonna get caught again
and i'm gonna go to jail again but in my
mind i'm thinking nah
i could do it this way maybe i'll just
deal with people over 30
a [ __ ] over 30 is gonna tell on
you it doesn't matter if he gets caught
with dope
i mean i got caught [ __ ] 100 feet
outside this door
and i was in here talking walked out the
door did something
and got caught and went to jail that
quick you know it can happen anywhere
because of the fact that
you always have to remember you have
good [ __ ] and you have bad
[ __ ]
and they run hand in hand you know what
i mean you gotta figure out
who you're gonna [ __ ] with who you're
gonna take care of business with
the best advice i ever got was if you do
it do it yourself
because only you know how you want it
done but if i send my homie
and he doesn't do it right i'm going to
[ __ ] him off
because i should have went and did it
myself but i sent him and expected him
to do the same thing
that i would do in my shoes that's
impossible he doesn't think like me
he's not going to think and do the same
things i would do in this situation
but we tend to think that i see a lot of
older dudes
on their homies for not doing what they
told them you should have [ __ ] did it
yourself
you know what i mean you sent a
[ __ ] to do what you would do in
a situation how the [ __ ] does he know
what you were gonna do
you got your own mind they got their own
mind you know what i mean that's why
i look around and i see all these
youngsters running around and oh my
homie told me to come over here and do
this and i'm looking at him and telling
man
your homie saying you do do the wrong
[ __ ] thing you know what i mean why
didn't he come
and i asked him why didn't your homie
come why did he send you
oh because he wants to take the credit
for all the work you're putting in but
he's gonna make the call he's gonna be
like hey man i got that done
he didn't do [ __ ] he just told you to go
do it you handled it
and he's getting all the credit you know
he's a vulture you gotta remember you
have those [ __ ] everywhere you
go
you have them in jail you have them out
here on the streets you know they want
to tell you do this do that and then
they take all the credit
and they're the ones shining when in all
reality you were the one that put in all
the work
he was the [ __ ] who just
verbally gave you the command
you know so you have to remember if you
want to be your own man and you want to
be that gangster that everybody looks up
to
well then you have to be your own man
you have to handle your own business
i've never asked anybody to go do
something that i wouldn't do myself
when i was in prison and i shared before
when i used to you know run away a tear
or yard and all that
before i told anybody to do anything i
did it myself right when i got there i
was the first [ __ ] to handle
business
so that when i would ask somebody else
to do it and they would run to their
homies and say why don't he go with us
his homies would tell him he will go
with us he already handled his business
he's not telling you to do something he
wouldn't do
that's the best advice i got man if
you're gonna do it do it yourself and
buy yourself
you know what i mean i hear
[ __ ] every day tell me i don't
need a gang
i'm my own man i can't knock him and
tell him he's wrong
because i was never my own man today
a little bit on my own man but i still
got my hood i still gotta represent i
still gotta
suffer the the repercussions of whatever
my hood does
if they put a light on all of us i get
the light too i'm no different than
anybody else
even though i put in work and lost all
of my life when i was a young man
all the people i stabbed all the mothers
i heard all the people i heard along the
way
my family i can't take none of that back
and i can't make it all better
all i got to do now is make sure
everything i do accordingly now
that it's the right thing i'm not saying
that i don't get high
and i don't go out there and party and
i'll sell drugs i'll be a [ __ ]
liar if i told you that
you know i mean but today i think in a
different fashion you know what i mean i
don't think it's sending my homework i
don't go get my homies
to handle business i don't really get on
the phone and call my homies to come 20
down
to come and handle my business [ __ ] no
i'm my own man if i [ __ ] did
something
then i gotta suffer the consequence what
it comes with you know i mean i share
that with everybody
i'm a strong believer and you get the
[ __ ] consequence you get
is how you carry yourself if you've been
around and you know better
then you should get off you should get
[ __ ] off because you know better
but if you're a beginner and you're a
new guy to the scene then they should
just talk to you
or make you do something they shouldn't
[ __ ] [ __ ] you off
you don't know no better when i was
younger man i used to roll around
pull my gun out everywhere until my
homies got a hold of me and [ __ ]
slapped me up and [ __ ] made me put my
gun away and told me what the [ __ ] are
you doing
why are you pulling that thing out why
you keep pulling it out and i thought i
pulled it out to look cool
now the only time you pull it out is to
use it you don't just pull it out to
show it
you don't mean and i had to learn that i
had to learn that very very [ __ ] up
they spoke to me in a way where
i didn't allow anybody to speak to me in
that way but yet because i was in the
wrong
and i was doing something that i
shouldn't have been doing when on all
reality
i thought it was the right thing i
thought roll by my homies in time i got
this and show them it
they [ __ ] blew it by the time i got
back they chewed my ass out
because i shouldn't have pulled nothing
out so i give that advice that you know
there's things you're gonna do in life
that are gonna affect
other people not just yourself i've
affected me in so bad of a way that i
got my kids are grown
adults and they're already adults they
don't need me anymore
now i didn't need them in the beginning
now i need them no they don't need me
you know and it's a [ __ ] up situation
but i share with you mark you know what
i mean i'll share some more do you want
mark
all right all right
you